[Musique]
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a dit vous parlez
français mais je vais essayer de parler
france mais vous ne pariez pas français
ya cinq ans vous tourniez unissent oui
oui j'ai tenus ou lis on est allé mais
avant ça comme vous vous souvenez j'ai
fait un film ici à paris et l'amour avec
j'ai fait de progrès formidable ça me
plaît beaucoup
puis vous avez aussi un autre changement
moi je me suis plus fait les cheveux
mais les vôtres ont drôlement allongez
vous êtes jaloux parce que j'ai pour les
cheveux plus longs que moi pourquoi mais
vous savez je suis en train de finir un
film c'est presque fini à londres sa
part l on dit en anglais de des blues de
st
commenté st bernard shaw oui exactement
cet oubli est assez agréable
oui et quels sont vos partenaires dans
ce film retourne avec burt lancaster un
vieux copain et selon un soulier mais
vous êtes tous les trois des acteurs
producteurs depuis cinq ans vous êtes
devenu producteur il ya d'ailleurs très
peu d'acteurs qui sont devenus
producteurs ayant continué mes yeux
oui et puis gregory peck winnipeg berlin
et coloris l'allier je crois aussi
marlon brando il faut quand même qu'un
acteur est incertain vis pour renoncer
au rôle confortable et agréable de
vedettes et se lancer dans la série
terrible d'ennuis que comporte le rôle
de producteur
voilà vous avez raison pour que vous
avez vous êtes depuis le producteur d'un
film qui s'appelle le viking qui va
sortir prochainement
oui exactement mais vous savez il ya
beaucoup de raisons pour devenir
producteur à l'époque il ya cinq ans
qu'on la télévision 5 6 ans qu'on est
télévision ont commencé il y avait
beaucoup de poteaux que nos producteurs
américains ils ont peur de faire ce
qu'ils ont pensé que avec les
télévisions on peut pas fait le cinéma
mais à mon avis j'ai pensé toujours il
ya en place aux télévisions
elle est en place pour
pour le cinéma c'est pour ça que j'ai
commencé ma compagnie pour la raison
contre entre télévision et le cinéma
et aussi parce que ça me plaît beaucoup
de faire plus de choses au cinéma au
loup d'être seulement un acteur oui mais
enfin il faut quand même avis pour aller
se jeter dans tous les ennuis que
nécessite non seulement la production
d'un film et d'un film d'un genre des
vikings qui est à grande mise en scène
je crois vous avez tourné un peu partout
dans le monde
oui les vikings et je crois c'était un
film le plus difficile à mon avis que
j'ai fait et peut-être gelé commencé
parce que j'étais un peu naïve randy
sanary oui exactement
parce que je n'étais pas sur tous les
problèmes que j'ai vu et voir pendant le
temps que que j'ai fait si vous les
aviez connu vous auriez quand même
commencer je ne sais pas je suis content
que les fils et sa fille ni exactement
parce que c'était vraiment
contre va être très très difficile
raconte et voient tous vos ennuis pour
le raconter tout ça va durer trop de
temps mais le problème le plus grave
était le mauvais temps en norvège parce
que j'ai décidé de faire le film
ces vikings ont le vrai pays la norvège
et il est plus presque tout le temps
vous avez une fois j'étais si triste
j'attends le beau temps et j'ai vu un
gars sont confiants garçons de norvège
il pleut et celui de mon b dites-moi
est-ce qu'il pleut toujours en norvège
est il mal il m'a répondu je ne sais pas
je n'ai que 18 ans douglas lui n'est pas
demeuré 18 ans dans les x de brumes du
nord mais des lacunes patience
d'archéologues
il a voulu tout connaître c'est pas
longtemps traîné dans tous les musées de
norvège et du danemark
il exigeait que chaque détail même peu
perceptible à l'écran fut minutieusement
reconstitué d'après les originaux qui
donc a dit que le cinéma détourner les
gens des scènes joie la culture générale
[Musique]
vous savez les vikings ne sont pas
exactement les enfants de choeur mais
vous n'avez pas non plus à des enfants
de choeur parce que vous savez en voyant
ce film j'ai passé une chose qui
m'inquiète dans vos films vous avez
l'air de toujours chercher la bagarre on
vous pas vous vous battez vous arrive
des accidents quand même ses rôles vous
avez choisi vous avez vous avez raison
je me suis rendu compte que dans la vie
de van gogh j'ai perdu où on aurait
maintenant dans les vikings j'ai perdu
un nom et je peux peut-être d'être moi
même j'ai un peu de viking c'est ça que
vous voulez dire oui mais écoutez
gardez-vous un ou une bouche pour vos
prochains rôles quand même ça c'est un
bon conseil je vais les suivre tout de
suite
[Musique]